it wasn't that i wanted to die i just
didn't care if i did
life and death were equally meaningless
to me equally neutral two sides of the
same coin that i would have happily
passed by on the street without picking
up
i was raised lutheran protestant
my parents and whole family were
extremely strong faith it was the
centerpiece to everything we did it all
all the sacraments the traditions the
rules the beliefs from top to bottom
when i was young the protestant doctrine
was just another truth of the world it
was as real and as true as why you look
both ways before you cross the street
as a young child your family is your
only real snorkel to the universe what
else are you supposed to believe other
than what the people who taught you how
to talk and act entire shoes and
everything else say
as i got a bit older though like most
teenagers do i started to question
everything most of my friends weren't
nearly as strong faith if they were at
all and some that were were of an
entirely different faith that
fundamentally contradicted mine it all
felt increasingly strange to me
increasingly hard to make sense of as
the reality of my family and childhood
collided head-on with the incompatible
reality of the world
at its core it was hard to disagree with
many of the moral ideals of
protestantism and christianity the
ethical righteousness the communal
kindness the forgiveness and discipline
but even at this age a lot of this stuff
just seemed like common sense to me and
as i got even older it seemed like these
parts didn't even really need faith at
all it was only the obscure big picture
stuff that really needed faith the parts
about god's will and grace salvation
what comes after death and what the
point of all this is
by the time i was 17 or 18 i had pretty
much realized that all of these parts
all the parts that depended on faith
were nonsense
soren kierkegaard wrote faith simply
means what i am seeking is not here and
for that reason i believe it
but i didn't believe anymore i didn't
believe one could believe in something
they didn't know for any good reason
other than desperation or lack of
authentic alternatives
i didn't believe in the scripture or god
i didn't believe there was any purpose
to life i didn't believe in an afterlife
i didn't believe in anything
following this period of my life i lost
all concern and became fairly reckless i
just wanted to do anything that would
potentially numb the nothingness of
being
as far as ways to potentially go i have
to believe this might be one of the most
interesting to realize you're in your
last moments of life while in free fall
must be one of the most poetic
sensations to intersect the human mind
initially when the main parachute failed
naturally i panicked a little but with
the backup parachute it felt more like
the panic that would come from falling
off a rock climbing wall while wearing a
rope i just needed it to catch me
after gathering myself a little i pulled
the cutaway handle and disconnected the
main parachute this immediately sent me
spiraling out of control though i
managed to restabilize myself enough and
pulled the reserve handle for the backup
parachute
nothing happened
i pulled at it again
still nothing
i don't know how many times in different
ways i pulled on it from here but i was
essentially just violently and
desperately yanking at nothing
there was nothing there to catch me
the feeling at this point was so beyond
describable your brain just can't
comprehend what is happening it panics
itself into an almost psychedelic state
of mind
there must have been just 40 or 50
seconds or so between me and the ground
i know it probably sounds like the most
cliched thing one could say here but
those 40 or so seconds lasted for what
felt like hours i don't mean to say that
just as some sort of expressive
hyperbole but i literally mean they felt
like they slowed into hours or even a
whole day perhaps a more accurate way of
putting it would be that time seemed to
almost stand still or no longer even
really exist at all
in the past i've read various works of
philosophers who argue that time is a
feature of the mind and not actually a
property of objective reality itself an
experience like this really makes you
take that seriously
merely because of my state of mind time
changed and almost disappeared
i wouldn't say my life flashed before my
eyes during this but in some impossibly
strange way items from my life seemed to
fly past me as if they were floating up
from earth's surface into the sky as i
approach the ground in super slow motion
i saw my dog my brother several of my
current and old friends my bike my
ex-girlfriend my computer my favorite
pillow my phone my car random pieces of
clothing sentimental possessions i've
held onto things i have hanging around
my apartment walls items from my kitchen
some of my favorite foods alcohol
bottles i saw dollar bills and credit
cards paperwork and other miscellaneous
items they all flew up and passed me
into the sky
at first as i watched these items drift
up and toward me i found myself thinking
about what i had already known now in my
adult life with death approaching
millisecond by millisecond inch by inch
its impending nature elucidated by this
immediate physical exemplification all
these things that were passing by were
about to be gone forever
not literally per se of course they
would outlast me physically but in the
sense that they existed in their form as
i knew them exclusively inside my head
and since my head was about to be no
longer neither would they
and so all of these things my life the
way i saw and understood everything in
but seconds would ultimately not matter
at all it would all go nowhere for
nothing
but yet despite this as these things
seemed to drift past me
i watched in agony
i had the sudden awareness that the
distance between me and the ground was
the distance between me and never seeing
my dog again never seeing my friends
again never meeting a new friend again
nor girlfriend or spouse never entering
into my apartment or home at the end of
a long day again never walking down a
street again never tasting food again
never experiencing any item or person i
had ever known again
we all know as a concept that eventually
we will do everything for the last time
there's no surprises here but knowing
this as a verbal construction versus
staring its truth dead in the eyes as it
approaches you from your feet and
seconds away is a totally different
thing
in this moment i not only felt the
survival instinct of my unconscious mind
kick in but i also felt an immense
despair and desire for life on the
conscious side of my being as well this
may seem less than interesting to you
but to me seeing as how for the prior
several years of my life i was convinced
that life didn't matter and i didn't
care if i died or not the fact that
everything mattered so much in this
moment even something as simple as just
the kitchen spoon i prefer to use was
revelatory
i realized in all of this that the
significance of these items the
significance of my life was not about
what it all meant beyond me or beyond
this life made clear by the clarity of
death even though none of it was coming
with me into the ground it all still
mattered
the meaning the significance came from
me while i was alive
it was around this moment that i sort of
came back too definitely not fully but
at least more than i was
in perfect irony though i realized
simultaneous to realizing that i
actually wanted to live that it didn't
matter that i now realized this there
was no hope i was falling at 200 feet
per second toward earth's ground
but yet despite this
i tried anyway
i flattened my body and tried to slow my
descent as best i could i scanned the
area around me and located a nearby
lining of trees and aimed toward it more
and more the trees grew from what looked
like one large mass of moss on earth's
surface to individual separate objects
growing in size and detail without even
thinking i positioned myself upright put
my legs forward back straight shoulders
up hands on my head
then
black
it felt like i was passing over to some
other realm of existence i remember
thinking to myself in one burst of dim
consciousness perhaps i was wrong
perhaps there is an afterlife
but in another subsequent burst some
time later i realized unless they carry
you to heaven on a stretcher in a
helicopter i was either hallucinating
dying or somehow
surviving it was mostly all black again
for a while
i awoke in a hospital bed several days
later
how could i have possibly survived such
a thing you're probably wondering
why did i what does it all mean
admittedly i wrestled with all of these
sorts of questions for a period of time
after but one of the many things i
realized from this whole absurd incident
is that things don't have or need grand
reasons or explanations beyond
themselves
why did i jump out of an airplane why
did my parachute fail why did my backup
why did i survive how did i why did i
think about skydiving in the first place
why was i born as someone who became
someone who did why was i born someone
at all why was the world and universe
these questions ultimately get you
nowhere with nothing but that's just it
you don't need them to go anywhere with
anything as long as you are here
that's where all questions and answers
ultimately start and end anyway
you here and now
the leap of faith in life i now believe
i've discovered is not in believing that
some meaning or point exists beyond you
or this life there is likely nothing to
hope for or believe in after the moment
of impact but the real leap of faith is
in believing that what exists down here
on the ground right now what you can
know and experience while you can know
and experience
is enough
i do not want to found anything on the
incomprehensible i want to know whether
i can live with what i know and with
that alone
wrote what has since the incident become
one of my favorite writers albert camus
i have not become naive i know there is
no hope for any grand gesture or
reconciliation of life i know it is all
for nothing everything made futile
mocked ultimately by death's approaching
supremacy
but the question is can i survive in the
face of this hopelessness
can i care and try anyway
i did it once already
i leaped from the abstract realm of the
heavens fifteen thousand feet up and
landed down on the material earthly
grounds of reality and survived and with
reason to
my story is a hymn for the absurd
[Music]
thank you so much for watching for
anyone interested in further supporting
the channel a small restock of clothing
is now live on the pursuit of wonder
website
both of my books notes from the end of
everything and the hidden story of every
person will be available again on the
website soon as well both books are also
available on amazon right now in
paperback and ebook format as well as
audiobook for notes from the end of
everything you can find all the links in
the description below and of course as
always thank you so much for watching in
general and see you next video